[music]
>> Let me quickly pass on the mic to
brother Zamri.
Brother Zamri.
As-salamu alaykum, brother Zamri. Wa
alaykumu s-salam wa rahmatullahi taala
wa barakatuh. Masha Allah.
So, prepared with the 50 surah names?
Insha Allah. Insha Allah.
I guess the session that which we had
the previous training day,
alhamdulillah, it must have really
helped you all to realize and understand
that we actually make our own
boundaries.
We put our own limitations and
restrictions.
If you truly follow the formula of
success,
then these obstacles, these
difficulties, these restrictions that
which we have put to ourselves will
unwound
on its own.
Did you realize that, brother Zamri?
Yeah. Alhamdulillah.
How much time did you spend for learning
the 50 surah names with meanings?
How much time did you take?
Have you learned it?
Yeah. Masha Allah. In how many hours?
So that our brothers sitting here who
are finding it more difficult than you,
at least learn
that you have put so many number of
hours and you were able to learn.
They get a sample. They get a model
in brother Zamri.
Just for the surah name?
Surah names. 50 surah names?
Maybe around 6 hours. With its meaning?
>> 6 hours, masha Allah. Anybody less than
6 hours?
Masha Allah.
How many of you have learned all 50?
All 50?
Brother Zamri,
raise your hand.
One.
You have learned as well, Abdul Malik.
Brother Azranchand?
No?
Masha Allah, brother Azran.
We saw your pictures yesterday.
The reality shows happening and you were
masha Allah relaxing. So we were
thinking and we were discussing, look
brother Azranchand, you know, he's just
relaxing.
So were you doing your homework
yesterday or were you relaxing?
All the while?
Both of them.
Both?
Which was more? Relaxing was more?
Homework was more? Quite a balance.
Quite a balance. So you divided your
entire time into two equal halves. Yes,
I I
I realized that I was, you know,
uh difficulty in
staying alert. So I figured that I need
a lot of
uh
How you say? Cut down on sleep.
Mhm. You know. And uh
And you found difficulty, did you follow
the formula of success?
Yeah, um
Yeah, I did. I did. And uh
So if you did it, then you should have
learned it.
Mhm?
You didn't do it
to its utmost best.
The greater the jihad you do, the
greater striving you do,
the more the help of Allah subhana wa
taala comes to you.
Insha Allah.
At least 25? First 25?
Less than that, I think. Insha Allah.
Insha Allah.
>> Say insha Allah.
>> Insha Allah. Insha Allah. Masha Allah.
Brother Fadhli.
Alhamdulillah.
I can see that masha Allah brother
Fadhli is wearing
the uniform cap of IRF now, masha Allah.
The star cap that which we call. You
know, this is the uniform of
those who are working with IRF. Masha
Allah, it's looking really very nice on
you.
Alhamdulillah. There's a color of white.
As-salamu alaykum wa rahmatullahi wa
barakatuh
to everyone.
Alhamdulillah. Um it has been a
struggle, indeed, to memorize
as we I think most of us here
we do not come from any Islamic
background.
And we find it difficult to memorize,
especially the verses.
And we did our best and we strive for
it. With the help of Allah subhana wa
taala, insha Allah, insha Allah, I say
it again,
that we will get better and better as we
adapt to Mumbai at the same time, which
we are trying to as well. So I believe
there are some brothers who are resting
more than the normal hours expected from
us.
But insha Allah, after some time we have
adapt and we understand how Islamic
Research Foundation is nurturing us and
how the methodology of
uh teachings.
Um so hopefully, insha Allah. How many
hours did you sleep? Um four.
The night before this, I think three
hours or less than that. I am working my
way back to Allah subhana wa taala
to ask for help. So I have to wake up
early, leave my room and go to a nearby
masjid, but unfortunately, the doors are
locked.
Um so
>> you inside? No. I They lock me outside.
No, the doors are unable to open,
actually.
And the night before we had a
good rest. Alhamdulillah, I think about
6 hours.
All in all, um I managed to
uh do and focus about maybe not less
than 6 hours. Alhamdulillah.
But still again, it's still not
entering. Even though we put on the
audio, we read, it's not entering.
Astaghfirullah.
Let me uh give the mic to brother Let me
uh give the mic to brother
uh Ibrahim Alzahrani, masha Allah,
who has joined us today to this
international Dawah Training Program
coming all the way from Kingdom of Saudi
Arabia.
So can anyone pass on the mic to brother
Ibrahim?
He would like to know
seeing the stage
and the entire setup. As-salamu alaykum
wa rahmatullahi wa barakatuh. Wa
alaykumu s-salam wa rahmatullahi wa
barakatuh. Yesterday, alhamdulillah, I
reached to Mumbai
7:30 a.m.
And uh
brother Sumair of
took me from the airport from the
airport to the hotel, but
where I couldn't find a room. So brother
Abu Shah jazak Allah khair from
Malaysia,
he invited me to his room.
I stayed and washed, then uh
then I went back to IRF Mhm. till I find
a room, then uh Dr. Zakir said that I
cannot go back to the hotel unless at
least I watch the two days back
of the sessions.
So I tried with the
one of the brothers
and uh I couldn't watch the full day
because uh
maybe I have two or three hours more to
finish the first session. Mhm. Or the
first day's session? First day's
sessions, yes. For the first day.
>> another three more hours remaining.
Yeah, from the first day. And I still
have the second day full.
Okay. Okay, so from maybe from 10:30
to 7:00 or 6:30
I was watching the
the sessions
with the brother.
But you were supposed to watch it from
11:00 in the morning, right?
The video arrangement was done from
11:00 in the morning. I reached there to
IRF maybe 10:00 I reached there to IRF
maybe 10:00 maybe 10:00 o'clock. Then I
went back with the brother to the
another place.
We watched maybe from 10:30 or 11:00.
I don't know, I can't remember really.
So insha Allah, we hope that tonight
you're going to stay awake and finish
the remaining video recording insha
Allah.
>> finish early, insha Allah, I got to do
it.
>> No, insha Allah. Whether we finish it
early or late, that's secondary.
The night time, insha Allah, we hope
that you finish watching the video
recording of the remaining number of
hours of day one and insha Allah the day
two as well. Brother Atiq, how many
hours have you completed?
As-salamu alaykum. Wa alaykumu s-salam.
How many hours on what? The first day's
recording and the second day's
recording. First [snorts] day I
completed completely.
And uh but I would say I watched around
80 to 85%.
And uh the second day I started and
maybe around a 1 hour was left.
>> Okay, insha Allah. So
>> hope that both the brothers, insha
Allah,
would watch the balance video of day one
as well as the day two, insha Allah.
That is it for the recap session for
today, insha Allah.
And let's move on quickly to reading out
the schedule for day three of this
international Dawah Training Program.
Have all the brothers received this? The
schedule for day three?
Yes?
International Dawah Training Program
conducted by Dr. Zakir Naik, the third
day. Today is Tuesday,
19th of January, 2016.
The theme for the day, as you can see it
written in bold and clear
techniques of giving Islamic talks.
So, alhamdulillah,
in the past 2 days, alhamdulillah, we
made sure that you all realize that the
success for this Dawah training program
and for any work you do in your life is
firstly the help of Allah Subhana Wa
Ta'ala.
Second is your striving. Is your jihad.
How much hard work do you put in? How
much efforts do you put in?
The third,
which is the least important, but it is
also important, is the techniques.
So, inshallah,
from this day and the coming day,
inshallah, we would be focusing on the
techniques of giving Islamic talks.
But never forget that though we are
doing the techniques today and the
coming day, the first two rules of
success
will be applicable throughout.
Without the help of Allah, without you
striving and putting in the hard work,
the techniques are not going to work.
That is precisely the reason why in the
beginning I recited the verse from Surah
An-Nahl, chapter 16, verse 43. And a
similar message is given in Surah
Al-Anbiya, chapter 21, verse number
seven. Allah Tabaraka Wa Ta'ala says,
"Fas'alu ahladh-dhikri in kuntum la
ta'lamun."
If you do not know, ask the person who
is an expert. Ask the person who has
knowledge.
Ask and learn the techniques.
So, inshallah, today's session will be
totally focused on the techniques of
giving Islamic talks, and you yourself
will realize that coming on the stage
and delivering a speech has so many
rules and regulations to be followed to
make your speech an effective speech,
inshallah. So, that is the theme of the
day.
Allah.
>> [music]
>> Allah.
Allah.
>> [music]
>> Allah.
Allah.
>> [music]
>> Allah.
Allah.